[Music]
hi there
Jimmy here always good to have you back
Jimmy in today's episode we're gonna be
focusing on different cloud functions
when building apps developers rely on
various cloud services including storage
messaging data analytics and mobile
development as developers expand their
use seamless integration between these
services can be a challenge very true so
today we'll introduce Google cloud
functions a solution that allows you to
connect services together and extend
their behavior just by adding code we'll
also run through a quick demo of a
self-paced lab that will allow you to
create deploy and test a cloud function
cloud functions sounds pretty generic to
me so what is it really
Google cloud functions can be summarized
as a service compute solution for
creating event-driven
applications so let's define an event an
event could be something like a change
to data in a database or files added to
a storage system you can create a
response to that event with a trigger a
trigger is an indication that you're
interested in a certain event or set of
events adding a cloud function to the
trigger allows you to respond to that
event because the software and
infrastructure are fully managed by
Google you only need to provide the code
a function can scale from a few requests
to millions per day without any work
from you click here to view a great
introduction by our product manager
Jason Polites about building service
applications with Google cloud functions
so what can you do with clout functions
let's look at some examples we can all
relate to all right I've got one you
know when you subscribe to a newsletter
Hogwarts number one fan and you
magically get an email delivered to your
inbox yep that's a trigger for a cloud
function developers can also take
advantage of cloud functions to offload
resource intensive work that wouldn't be
practical to run on a user's device an
example could be to write a function
that upon upload of an image to a
storage bucket a thumbnail of the image
is created and then saved in another
bucket it's another great example Jimmy
and of course there are many
opportunities to integrate with
third-party services and API stew now
two quick laps the cloud functions lab
is available for use with the command
line as well as through the Google cloud
platform console you can check out the
links to start to quick labs here in
both labs you will create a cloud
function deploy and test the function
and view logs so far in the lab we've
created a cloud function based on an
HTTP trigger and deployed it once
deployed you can test a function provide
a triggering event in this case a simple
hello world message you can see the
success of the tested function in the
output field you can easily see the logs
for your function well there we have it
thanks for watching our quick video on
Google cloud functions don't forget to
keep visiting our on-air webinar series
quick labs and our blogs all the links
are below you can also learn more about
cloud functions there are on-demand
courses on Coursera thanks for watching
and see you soon
last week we discussed Google kubernetes
engine and how it can easily scale
deploy and automate your application
check out the video and the quick lab
demo here